since the conference app doesn't use
touch that much we're going to have you
take a look at adding touch support to a
different example let's take a look at
how we would code a simple drawing
application on a web page
first let's look at this as we would
write it for the mouse
you can see where we've hooked the mouse
down mouse move and mouse up events and
you can see our handlers for each one of
these it simply creates a new stroke and
then adds points to that stroke as we go
now we'd like you to change this code to
use pointer events don't forget to set
the touch action attribute on the html
element that you're using as an event
listener
we've already included the polymer
polyfill so you don't need to worry
about doing that just change the event
handlers to be pointer events and then
make any appropriate changes to the
handlers themselves if there are any